so uh you guys are making movies we are
daily wire uh you're making shows too
what's how does it come to be that the
daily wire you guys you guys are our
news aggregators and commentators for
the most part now you're in this
cultural space
yeah how does that happen it was always
part of the vision right we we the
company was founded in la obviously
ben's lived in la every minute that he
wasn't at harvard i spent 20 plus years
in la before moving the company to
nashville at the end of 2020 andrew
clavin screenwriter novelist was with
the company from the very beginning
there's always been this really
kind of hollywood
foundation to what we do you know i made
a bunch of movies in in a previous life
that
they all failed but i made them i'm
proud of them um and so when when ben
and i made the decision that we wanted
to get into business together one of the
things that that i told him and it was
an idea that
another conservative commentator bill
whittle
helped me formulate was that if we built
a media company that was large enough we
would actually have a spotlight and we
could shine that spotlight on
other kinds of projects that we might
want to make what happened and so
for me that was always movies like i had
a production company with with some
young actors uh when i was in my early
and mid-20s i had a production company
later in life called declaration
entertainment that was sort of
just
just probably ahead of its time and
underfunded to actually be what it maybe
could have been but was sort of intended
to be like a crowd crowdfunding uh film
company before there were crowdfunding
companies the
so that was always part of what i wanted
but i thought what we would do is we
would build up a big enough audience
that if i went and made something on the
side i could promote it to me that's how
i saw it but what happened to in 2020
you know
everybody went home because of covid our
office is on ventura boulevard in la
it's the second time we've had to board
up because black lives rally is is uh
black lives matter is rallying on the
street and we're afraid they'll burn
down our building and i'm so i'm on this
the third floor of this office building
with my business partner it's completely
empty because no one's been to work in
weeks and weeks and weeks
and i said hollywood's over
like what can they make now they've
they've decided that the police are bad
literally 40 of everything that
hollywood makes is about a cop
they can't do anything if this is the
position they're going to take and
that's when we realized not only had we
built that spotlight that ben and i had
always wanted to build
but we had built something else too we
had actually built
the distribution mechanism because we
had built this streaming video on demand
platform for our podcast for the video
versions of our podcasts and it just
occurred to us in that moment you know
the technology is agnostic as to what
the content is we've essentially built
netflix we just haven't put movies on it
yet
so if we if we
bring in the one other thing you need
for for a successful entertainment
company is just production if we bring
in production we actually have marketing
and distribution why don't we give that
a try and as
because you know i know there isn't a
god but if you ever think about how
if you ever think about how the world
has so much purpose and how everything's
so complex and beautiful it's almost
like a god-like being probably from
outer space built at all not god because
that would be a silly thing to say like
a crazy person but like just a god-like
being you know if you really think about
it
that when the god-like being sometimes
there's this like
fortuitousness or providence that
happens in the world and as we're having
this thought dallas sonja who's been a
guest on this show
called me and said hey
i made this great movie called run hide
fight
and hollywood won't buy it because i've
basically been blacklisted and we just
saw that as an opportunity to test the
theory if we put a great production
through our marketing and through our
distribution mechanism what will happen
it was an unbelievable success for us
the movie paid for itself in something
like
seven days and we realized
we realized that we had an actual now
opportunity and and i always think
opportunities are always
responsibilities so now when i say we
have a responsibility to go chase this
let me tell you about impact
i would i would like uh for you sir to
please read the headline on the screen
i
i watched a bin shapiro movie by
accident that's right yeah this is some
leftist who watched i believe they
watched shutting
and liked it so much they tweeted how
much they liked it saying if you're
looking for something to watch shut in
is pretty fun and vincent gallo gets his
ass kicked if you're that sort of thing
that's a tweet i wrote a couple weeks
ago late on saturday night it no longer
exists the reason doesn't exist is
because almost immediately after i
posted it i got a dm from a friend uh
you know that movie was produced by the
ultra right-wing daily wire with only
ultra right-wing producers talent and so
forth for the market um what no no
delete delete what yep they're trying to
make real movies now sneak that ish in
under the cover of actual production
values for f's sake this always happens
to me i will be watching an ultra
evangelical movie and that realizes
ultra evangelical i'll be listening to
christian radio and i realize it's a
christian radio if jesus is around i
need him to announce himself or i'll
just think he's from brooklyn the funny
part the funny thing about this is that
i hope it's satire and it may be but um
i'm assuming it's not i don't know it's
the great it's the greatest article i
mean at the end
they say maybe if you keep doing this
maybe one day i'll watch one of your
movies on purpose
but but here's
real quick we did talk about the other
day but i just want to point out uh you
know with you here your thoughts this is
someone who's saying they actually
really enjoy
evangelical movies or the daily wires
content
but
it says a lot that they're unwilling to
watch things they enjoy
because of of cult-like behavior and so
the the point i made before we on the
show is
thinking about your commercial with
jeremy's razors it's it's an objectively
funny commercial
okay obviously you know humor is
addictive to a lot of people but it's
it's very much in line with a lot of the
you know the real american heroes bits
that were happening out through the
2000s 2010s you know real men of
whatever and that stuff and it's an
over-the-top it's silly use a
flamethrower to torch and there's a lot
of jokes it's funny the the native
american elizabeth warren you have
standing behind you a lot of jokes in
there the people who claim it's not
funny they don't like it they're only
saying that because they're part of a
cult they have to adhere to that's right
privately they admit they like your
movies but they must say they don't like
it for the sake of their political tribe
well also when these people say
something isn't funny am i supposed to
sit there and go well you know the
things you think are hilarious tend to
be really valuable and enjoyable to
watch so of course i trust your opinion
on this
none of their comedy is good but part of
why i think this and i could be wrong
part of why i think that this is
probably satire is because unfortunately
most of the stuff that conservatives and
evangelicals make tends not to be funny
or entertaining and they're saying that
they keep seeing things made by
evangelicals that they don't know are
evangelical which is kind of part of why
i'm thinking it's satirical but it could
be wrong i'd like to quote um
justin roiland or his character rick
sanchez
your booze mean nothing i've seen what
makes you cheer yeah
so there you go i mean first of all the
funny thing is
they cheered for you guys your guys
movie and they're only doing it now when
they realized who made it i'm like no
you can't take it back you cheer for it
we know you like it yeah that's right
yeah yeah as an insecure artist uh
you know anytime anybody says they like
anything that i did i don't hear
anything they say after that it's
no bad it's all about us yeah
so what's the plan what's what's next tv
shows tv shows movies we you know as
with the razer company we just see a lot
of opportunity in
in the destruction that the left is is
bringing to the culture right now i mean
i think it's tragic listen if i could
snap my fingers and put the country back
together and have everything be like it
was back when i grew up i'd probably do
it if i could be dictator that's what
i'd i'd just say hey it should be 1990s
all over again i kind of liked the night
the 90s
yeah like there was no the races all got
along and everybody was doing it pretty
well
not bad that's right transformers beast
wars come on dude 97.
but you can't do that and it would be
disingenuous for us to say
in all of this uh destruction there's
not an opportunity for creativity no
absolutely there is and we should take
it but
well i totally agree and this is part of
why i got into this fear firstly i just
always wanted to make entertaining
content i i lean right people on the
show who watch me regularly know this
and what ended up happening is i just
got to a place after i launched my
channel and was doing these political
cartoons for a little while where i just
realized i didn't really need to try to
put a message into anything i just
needed to make something that i thought
was funny and my values would naturally
come out in it so often what happens
when conservatives try to make content
or evangelicals christians even
catholics try to make content is they
will really hit you over the head with
what the central message is supposed to
be instead of just making something
that's enjoyable to watch and it turns
out really cheesy now what's ended up
happening over the past couple years is
the left has adopted that strategy and
so much of what they produce is message
first substance later and so you're
absolutely correct that they're tearing
their whole empire down because i
remember as a kid we used to watch films
and television shows from the 1950s or
60s with our dad and he would make
comments about how they could never make
that today now we're saying that about
things that were made 10 years ago yeah
that's right
um how do you guys get around the esg
stuff that's been coming
you're familiar with what what is it in
environmental social governance yeah
yeah so real quick for those that aren't
familiar this is basically social credit
scores for businesses and they expect
you to be woke to have these you know
diversity statements otherwise they
could negatively impact your ability to
get loans and things like that
so the daily wires making all this
content you guys are are going after
culture but isn't there a risk there if
these other institutions come at you
yeah i mean there's a lot of risk
everywhere one of the problems i think
that conservatives face right now in in
the economy more broadly is there are so
many potential vectors of attack
uh and you could put a lot of money into
chasing any one of them and then that
could just not be where the attack comes
so you wasted all of your resources
trying to plan for a disaster that never
came and now the disaster can come from
a whole other angle an example of this
conservatives want to build their own
social media platforms right now you
know you hear every time i talk to any
sort of like conservative billionaire
the first thing they say is when are we
going to get a facebook and i say uh
facebook is 20 years old bud
you will probably get one ten years from
now it's been half a biblical generation
since it was created so i think that
you're you're getting close soon you
will have one but that's the whole
problem with conservatism uh from an
investment class point of view most
concern high net worth conservatives
made their money in energy or they made
their money in real estate they made
their money in agriculture very
conservative ways of making money
uh the result of that is if a kid with a
backpack walks into their family office
and says hey i designed an app that lets
you rank how hot girls on campus are i
think if you gave me a little capital i
could turn it into the dominant
communication platform
ever conceived in all of human history
they would call security and throw that
guy out now 20 years later they go why
don't we have a seat at that table but
if the if a kid with a backpack walked
in now and pitched them blockchain or
pitched a meta they would have the same
reaction that they had 20 years so it's
like i bet we have a conservative
facebook in 10 years and i bet that we
have a conservative metaverse in 45
years from now right like that's that's
the problem and so
but as with all problems it creates
certain opportunity we found an early
investor in our company who was able to
get us off the ground we
took money from them that helped us for
the first 14 months in month 14 the
daily wire was cash flow positive we've
paid for all of our growth
since then out of cash flow we did 120
million dollars of revenue in the last
12 months
uh you know it's a it's a sometimes i
get angry when people are like
billionaires pay for everything you do
no no no
like many companies we we were
privileged to get some startup capital
so but we funded all of this out of our
success so you're just saying uh daily
wire pulls in 10 million a month yep and
because and because of that the esg
stuff right now doesn't apply to us
right we don't because we funded our own
growth it's it's sort of like your
situation here you've built something
now you didn't even have the amount of
startup capital that we had but you've
built something that you own and because
you own it you can't be cancelled from
it you can't be thrown out of it now
our goal at the daily wire is to become
an institution our goal at the daily
wire is to challenge the left
on an institutional level because we
think that's the only place that true
victory can take place
maybe at some point we'll have to go to
the public markets
but what we won't do is get caught up in
the csgs like
it may come to at a certain point we
have to decide do we subject ourselves
to forces that change what we are or do
we
not grow and what
the risk i see is uh yeah
well i'll i'll phrase it this way when i
watched that commercial you put out
when i saw the building you were in and
the tv and the structure i'm like that
reminds me of vice you know when i when
i worked there when they were edgy when
they were offensive when they were
shocking the way they designed their
buildings and i was like man is the
daily wire like
vice now like how they used to be
how did vice go from being sex drugs and
rock and roll into wokeness outright you
know establishment and there comes a
time hundreds of millions in
institutional capital they go public but
it's uh they well they want to i think
they're trying to go through a spack
they've wanted to for a while my
understanding is what i was told by
former higher-ups who are at the company
is that
they had been attacked so many times by
their harassment complaints sexual
harassment
that the press was bad
and they had paid people out and there
was a risk of certain stories going
public
so their investors said just declare
yourselves like a feminist company like
make feminist content adopt this and
you'll shield yourself from these claims
and so the id this is what i was told
that um and this is someone who was like
i worked with i worked at vice they said
when the investors came in and said be a
feminist company and you will be safer
from these attacks they said okay
because the executives didn't care so my
understanding was are is they were just
like hey whatever gets people off our
back you guys no problem we just want to
make cash and run a business none of
these executives care disney doesn't
care about the grooming law down in
florida right of course they don't they
what they care about is their 23 year
old woke employees
um making it impossible for them to
conduct their business what they care
about is the fact that the left is so is
so skilled at weaponizing and they want
to avoid those attacks of their business
and so it's a it's a the thing about
virtue is that it's actually a really
cheap currency you just say something
hollywood's always peddled in this you
know even in the glory days of the 90s
you know and we're all walking around
second on a big gulp or whatever uh you
know everybody in hollywood wanted to
save the freaking whales because of
course they want to save the wells
because when you're on like your third
marriage and yep four out of your five
kids are in rehab and uh you gotta save
something i guess yeah you want everyone
needs to see themselves as good on some
level and if you're good for christians
do this too by the way it
everyone an easy out is to find an
abstract way to be good you know it says
in one of the epistles written by the
apostle john that
it's easier to love your neighbor whom
you know than to love god
and christian every time you talk to a
christian i go well that's not really
true i mean my neighbor is kind of a
jerk my brother's kind of a jerk but of
course i love god and i said well you
don't i mean
god himself in the epistle says that you
don't you say that you do because you've
abstracted a god that you can love
more than your brother whom you know
you've created a god to love who
approves of you and who doesn't have
anything that you disapprove of your
neighbor your brother who you know has
all kinds of crap that you don't approve
of and so you see like it's very easy to
give money to african missionary work or
african charities or to save the whales
or to save the environment these are
ways of abstracting your way out of
having to deal with the messy reality of
the world if you really care about
people
you interact with those actual people
and try to make their
make improvements into their lives right
yeah i would actually agree with that
and i would go as far as to say when
somebody says that they love god but
they hate the people around them don't
do anything to improve their
circumstances either material or
spiritually that person really worships
themselves because their vision of god
is just
as you said something abstract that
caters to all of their particular
desires one thing that i think our
society has really lost is people are
not focused as much on what is near to
them they want to solve problems on the
other side of the world that's a huge
part of progressive politics in fact you
could argue it's the only part of
progressive politics is to defer
responsibility elsewhere historically
people understood you were supposed to
love those closest to you care for your
family first and foremost and then you
started to worry about the people around
you now it's the exact opposite i can
treat my family horribly but as long as
i am theoretically good to someone on
the other side of the world i'm a good
person even though my entire social life
is a complete failure the uh greatest
psychologist of our time has a statement
jordan peterson you have to clean your
room man but but that's that's that's
exactly the meme
you can't change the world if you can't
even get your own life in order yeah but
i want to point something else out too
um well also when i'm when i'm looking
at this article from defector and
they're holding up a sign saying f you
ben ish pirro like just cussing at him i
think to myself
i don't i don't recall seeing
conservatives holding up signs
saying f.u jenk yuger or
to be fair obviously sometimes they do
but it's kind of a common occurrence
among the left to hate
and to hate without trying to understand
yeah so i was i'm thinking about daryl
davis he's been working with bill ottman
over at mines they want to de-radicalize
extremists not de-platform them it's one
of the things they're working on and
daryl davis you know he's the guy who
went to clan meetings a black man and
just talked to these people trying to
understand them ends up de-radicalizing
them it's fascinating because
when i see
how the the modern left the activists
left not like regular run-of-the-mill
you know democrat voters they're you
know mostly just regular people are
paying attention maybe but these
activists just they hate they hate so
much it's the weirdest thing that glenn
beck can tell dave rubin i disagree with
you and i think what you're doing is
wrong but i love you
and what do they say they say f you ben
ish piro i'm like man glenn beck tells
the people he disagrees with that he
loves them they tell you they hate you i
don't understand why anybody would want
to be a part of that yeah well this is
the problem
with
dogma and ideology and politics is that
they allow you not to have to actually
engage with the world as it is
you're only required to engage with the
world sort of as you perceive it
juxtaposed against a code of your
essentially of your own making and
people can say well no my dogma is is 2
000 years old or my dogma is uh well as
you know comes straight from athens or
whatever it is but the truth is uh
if you're a person who can't engage in
reality
then your dogma is an abstract your
dogma is just a reflection of things
that you want and it's a way of to your
point mitigating responsibility for the
actual people around you you know you
i've thought a little bit about our
i actually was about to say something
that i had committed not to say on the
air so i'm not going to say it nice work
thank you it's it's rare that i make a
good decision but i just made it good
i hear you but it's so it's so important
you know god if you're going to believe
in god or the god-like alien who
actually made the heavens and the earth
there's a whole conversation there
you actually have to believe like god
has to be the god of reality i i took a
friend 10 years ago i i'm married uh to
a woman i never talk i know i won't say
her name or talk about her too much but
i will tell you this funny story that uh
i i took a friend's future in-laws out
to a movie 10 years ago and the first
thing that that his future mother-in-law
said to me after the movie was i said oh
did you enjoy the movie and she goes
well i don't really like movies that's
oh great
and she said uh
you know
you you and your wife are mary so yeah
we've been married a short amount of
time she said well you know in god's
eyes she's still married to her first
husband
and and i said oh well god must be an
idiot wrong because that's not true but
that's not that is not reality god has
to be the god of reality not the god of
an abstract fantasy but i think i so i
would argue as a christian that's an
abstract fantasy that you can divorce
and remarry if it was a legitimate
marriage in the first place because one
of the definitions of marriage is that
it's a lifelong commitment until death
do you part
but what would you argue as a sheamus
as a shameless i mean that's my belief
do you like you actually believe it or
do you just believe that the christians
believe it no i believe it i mean i
believe i i think most christians don't
believe it unfortunately i
i think a lot of christians have
abandoned that it's not a popular
teaching anymore i suppose you could
define the word marriage meaning to mix
so if you're going to mix your soul with
something if there is a god if there's
an energy field there's no one mixing
that soul that's a good point well no
there's no there's no one unsaluting a
solution but i think you can reverse a
mixture if you mix red and blue paint
together you ain't getting them back out
mm-hmm
right yeah i mean that that that i don't
know it's a meaningless analogy so i
understand it though yeah but let's
let's let's i'll i'll push back on that
just a little bit sure god's the god of
reality the worst exists in the bible uh
that's not a recommendation of divorce
which is a horrible terrible thing
but the the idea that god lives in a
sort of abstract where things are as
they should be
how far back do you
how far back do you take that
essentially if that's the case then god
still lives in eden before the fall
happened god still lives in a place
where people haven't been living in sin
where people haven't been making
mistakes where none of the sort of
causal you know none of the
eventualities that came from that
causality of sin have ever occurred and
god is abstracted out of being the god
of actual people in an actual place in
an actual time
the god of the god of the bible in my
estimation is a god
who actually took on sin and took on the
consequences of sin on himself in christ
as a result of that he becomes god of us
of a reality that's
he becomes god of the people who have
existed in reality not just the people
who could have existed in the abstract
so i just think that any time that we
used see this is a great example that's
a place where we use sort of a dogma or
an ideology to deny a reality that's
right in front of us i think you see it
a lot with what's happening in in
ukraine right now by the way where
regardless of your opinion about nato
expansion regardless of your opinion
about
the merits of zalinski regardless of
your opinion about a lot of things like
vladimir putin actually did invade
ukraine and ukraine did not want to be
invaded and you see a lot of people left
and right but particularly on the right
who are almost in denial
about that situation because it doesn't
line up with their political point of
view they have a political point of view
that
that ukraine shouldn't have done certain
things
or or or that
putin was more friendly to the west than
he actually turned out to be or that
friend or that putin was a better
representative even you even hear people
on the right right now saying that putin
was a better representative of
christianity because he built a
cathedral you know at one point in time
or something and then actual reality
takes place in front of them they have a
very hard time pivoting to accept it
because it's because it's out of line
with their expectations based on how
they thought the world should be
yeah
man of the year
and they did appease him for a long time
so i i hear some what you're saying and
i i agree with some of what you're
saying but i would say where we
definitely disagree is that i would
argue that god
having moral prescriptions for us that
we ourselves do not live up to does not
mean that he's over abstracted or
doesn't govern our reality because it's
actually christ in scripture who who
says
what uh god has has brought together let
no man put asunder in it and anyone who
leaves their husband commits adultery
etc the challenge he also says if you
have lust in your heart you are an
adulterer yeah you're not an adult
you're not on the path to adultery
you're not kind of like an adulterer if
you really think about it yeah you are
one i want you if you're in a marriage
and you're thinking about having sex
with another woman does that make you
cheating on your wife yes that's
adultery of the heart that's crazy how
do you control your thought like you got
to learn to control your thoughts yeah
absolutely custody of thoughts i mean
nothing happens in the world that didn't
first happen in the human heart well
let's let's i would actually disagree i
think the entire purpose of the sermon
on the mount is to get us out of these
abstractions it's to con it's to bring
the full weight of condemnation to it's
so that no one can claim not to be an
adulterer not so that we can also try to
figure out how to not commit adultery in
our heads i so i would absolutely agree
that people should not be sitting here
and it is certainly not not my claim to
say that i am not a sinner or that i
have not committed adultery of the heart
etc it's simply to say that i don't
believe recognizing that negates the
moral precepts that that christ put
forth thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there